she says that jokes are too simplistic
they convert her trauma into humor
one could argue the point of humor and
obscure the ugly truth of her story I
just can't imagine [ __ ] listen there
it's like all was raped people feel good
when we laugh I feel better when I
laughed it's like the laughing -
laughing yogi really really no you must
have seen this advertised by Netflix
speaking of that laughing of stroke
sorry so it's highly acclaimed comedy I
was talking about finally someone sent
it
remember I said I it was the problem of
Netflix is you get these previews that
just start it just started playing and
you're like hey Paxton he's not still
around this is an old one but Netflix is
playing and then you can't find it again
yeah thank you for set I don't number
who sent it but I said please send along
yeah this thing
it's an acclaimed comedy special Nanette
in which she announces that she's
interesting all kinds of press for
quitting comm here's a here's a clip I'm
not a man hater but I am afraid of men
if I'm the only woman in a room full of
men I am afraid and if you think that's
unusual you're not speaking to the women
in your life I don't hate men but I
wonder how a man would feel if they'd
have lived my life because it was a man
who sexually abused me when I was a
child
oh wait this is comedy no she goes on to
say so this whole it's the anti comedy
special she says that jokes are too
simplistic they convert her trauma into
humor one could argue the point of humor
and obscure the ugly truth of her story
I don't think obscuring the ugly truth
yeah there's not enough tarps in the
world comedy she says has prevented her
from evolving and this is like this is
comedy now look we've talked about how
comedy is no longer funny yeah this is
actually being praised as founding
letting edge drown breaking huh ah
listen
oh I'll pitch an idea okay a comedy
special without me laugh no one that's
all get it sexist not funny
wait for it wait for it
and all funny company without laughs I'm
sorry I'm gonna have to turn that down I
am a lesbian though a proud I mean it's
it's it's comedy without last is called
spoken word or also being a douche yes
she's also gonna have a cameo in suport
sermon today she turns out it worked
well for her also a short it turns out
that by the way that we're giving her
too much to do we're being a little bit
harsh on special was hilarious they just
forgot to mix in the microphones with
the audience thanks to mug Club we
actually exclusive of the real clip the
remastered one it was a man who beat the
[ __ ] out of me when I was 17 rape that's
a funny word can I use that she's worse
than bania and that was worse than we
thought in the pitch meeting when I saw
you know all the different do we have to
hold a free market like accountable for
this or who's buying tickets no there is
no free market that's it Netflix is that
they're trying to manipulate the free
market true is shoe so they're just
pushing through this like it's like
Goldman Sachs they just think whose
money are they spending I don't know
somebody with too much of it's like I
just can't imagine like it's the only
job it's the one thing that I've always
I don't like it about musical artists we
were talking about this kind of reason
about Kurt Cobain and actually great
song by cat par bhai understand you
don't want to play the same thing
forever that being said you are a
performer people do pay you to perform
and in comedy they pay you to make them
laugh I'm very aware of that it's only
jobs like a plumber shows up as well
you've somebody to clean your your pipes
out yeah I'm just here to talk about
rape hey there YouTube viewer if you
like this video I would say subscribe
hit the notification bell or watch one
of these videos playing in a box that
we've personally uploaded in program for
your viewing pleasure the problem is now
in today's day and age on YouTube in
2018 any of those three things that you
do any of those three buttons that you
click will take you directly to a Seth
Meyers video
so stay here and join my get off of here
got a lot of credit accomplished buckle
up it's the only safe place you can go
enjoy